Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu 34. Ausgabe unserer kleinen Gesprächsreihe, die mich dieses Mal ein weiteres Mal nach Holland geführt hat zum Estec-Standort der ESA. Und der Grund und Anlass ist ein Thema, was hier in einer anderen Sendung schon mal ganz grob angeschnitten wurde. In Ausgabe Nummer 7 ging es um Weltraumschrott, wo wir ausführlich die Thematik besprochen haben, dass der Orbit in zunehmendem Maße von allerlei Zeug zugemüllt wird und was man dagegen tun kann. Ein Thema, was dabei leicht angerissen wurde, war das Projekt SSA, Space Situational Awareness. Und da ist es natürlich in der Zwischenzeit auch weiter vorangegangen. Und um dieses Thema jetzt ein wenig mehr aus einer anderen Perspektive zu beleuchten, begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner Detlef Kroschny. Hallo.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Du bist hier Wissenschaftler am STEC.
Wie lange schon? Ich bin jetzt seit fast 14 Jahren hier in Holland. Ziemlich genau.
Oh, also kennst alle Wege.
Na, vor allem die Fahrradwege.
Genau, das fahrradfreundliche Land ist hier auch auf dem Gelände nicht anders. Wie bist du denn überhaupt so hierher gekommen? 14 Jahre ESA, heißt das, dass man da vorher gar nichts anderes gemacht hat?
Doch, doch. Ich habe angefangen im Münchner Raum. Ich habe in München ursprünglich Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik studiert, dann zwei Jahre in der Industrie gearbeitet und bin dann aber wieder an die Uni zurück, weil ich eigentlich lieber in der Wissenschaft tätig sein wollte. Ich habe dort promoviert und bin dann über den Umweg Max-Planck-Institut in Kartlenburg-Lindau, in der Nähe von Göttingen, bin ich dann hier zu ESA gekommen. Und zwar eigentlich war das Thema, was sich so durch mein Leben immer zog, war auch die Rosetta-Mission, um die es ja auch schon früher mal in einer deiner Sendungen ging.
Richtig.
Und das war auch das Projekt, wo ich an dem Max-Planck-Institut gearbeitet habe und wo ich dann auch bei der ESA angefangen habe.
Was heißt so Asteroiden waren schon immer ein Thema?
Mich haben die kleinen Körper im Sonnensystem eigentlich schon immer interessiert, wie wir die nennen, also Kometen, Asteroiden. Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe als Schüler schon, habe ich mich nachts rausgelegt und Sternschnuppen angeschaut. Na ja, und Asteroiden sind einfach ja nur ein bisschen große Sternschnuppen. Und Kometen sind, die meisten jedenfalls, die Erzeuger von Meteorströmen. Und irgendwie, warum sucht man sich irgend so ein Thema aus? Ich weiß es nicht, aber da ist es gut.
Du hast die richtige Sternschnuppe im richtigen Moment gesehen.
Da habe ich mir wohl was gewünscht und dann ist es in Erfüllung gegangen.
Ja, und war das dann auch gleich das Thema hier am Estic?
Ich habe anfangs eben bei der Rosetta-Mission mitgearbeitet und bin aber mittlerweile ein bisschen in einem anderen Tätigkeitsfeld aktiv, eben diesem Space Situational Awareness Program, wo es natürlich auch um Asteroiden unter anderem geht, auch über Weltraumwetter und eben über diesen Weltraumschrott. Und ich bin da sozusagen, man macht halt nicht immer das Gleiche. Irgendwann vor fünf, sechs Jahren habe ich halt Rosetta verabschiedet aus meinem persönlichen Berufswege. Aber das wird wieder zurückkommen.
Sobald die Mission ja noch lange nicht abgeschlossen ist.
Es geht eigentlich erst los.
Die Tiefschlafphase wurde ja eingeleitet. Darüber haben wir hier auch ausführlich berichtet. Beziehungsweise der Gerhard Schwem, berichtet der ja auch hier im Estec eigentlich so sein Zentrum hat. Ja, was muss man sich jetzt vorstellen unter SSA? Was verbirgt sich hinter der Abkürzung und was für ein Fass wird da aufgemacht?
SSA steht für das englische Wort Space Situational Awareness. Und es gibt auch eine deutsche Übersetzung. Das ist irgendwie die Weltraumlage Erfassung. Und das finde ich also ein ganz schreckliches Wort. Deswegen würde ich eigentlich lieber das englische Wort gebrauchen.
Was macht das englische Wort so viel besser?
Ich weiß es nicht. Vor allem ist es leichter auszusprechen.
Du könntest ja auch von Weltraumverkehr sprechen. Das hat so ein bisschen was davon.
Ja, das könnte sein. Space Situational Awareness oder Weltraumlage Erfassung. Ich will wissen, was im Weltraum vor sich geht. Das große Thema ist, wir wollen verstehen, was im Weltraum passiert. Und zwar insbesondere wollen wir die Sachen verstehen, die uns beeinflussen. Also zum einen die Satelliten, die wir auch oben im Weltraum haben. Aber auch uns hier unten auf der Erde. Und daraus folgt dann auch diese Dreiteilung, die ich vorhin schon genannt habe. In der ESA hat SSA drei verschiedene Bereiche. Wir nennen das drei Segmente. Das erste Segment und das, wo auch am meisten Geld reinfliegt, das nennen wir Survey and Tracking. Und da geht es um den Weltraummüll und auch um ganze Satelliten, die dort oben rumfliegen.
Also eigentlich um alles, also sowohl die Satelliten, die in Operation sind, als auch diesmal waren, aber noch nicht den Weg zur Erde zurückgefunden haben.
Richtig. Und da gehören zum Beispiel auch dieser Weltraummüll. Das sind halt zum Beispiel Bruchstücke von Satelliten, wenn mal irgendeiner kaputt gegangen ist. Das kann auch einfach Reste sein vom Start einer Rakete. Dann werden da Sachen abgesprengt und dann fliegen da Farbpartikel rum. Und wenn die zum Beispiel die Raumstationen treffen, weil die recht hohe Geschwindigkeiten haben können, dann hat also auch schon ein ganz kleines Teil eine ziemlich verheerende Wirkung. Und deswegen will man die verfolgen. Man will wissen, wo sind die eigentlich, wo fliegen die rum? Und als nächsten Schritt wird man versuchen, auch dagegen was zu machen, den Müll irgendwie wieder wegzuräumen. Das ist Teil eins. Da können wir ja gleich nochmal drauf zurückkommen, aber ich will eben den Überblick noch abrunden. Das zweite Segment beschäftigt sich mit Weltraumwetter. Was ist denn Weltraumwetter? Da ist hauptsächlich die Sonne die Ursache. Von der Sonne geht ständig ein Strom von Partikeln weg, Protonen, alles Mögliche, also nicht nur Licht, was wir sehen können. Und das stört uns. Wenn zum Beispiel auf der Sonne eine große Protuberanz ausbricht, dann kommen die Strahlen, also diese Teilchenstrahlung kommt irgendwann, dann zeitversetzt.
Also Protuberanzen sind diese riesigen Explosionen, die man dann immer bestaunt, wenn man sie mal in einem Video wieder mal vorgezeigt bekommt.
Und die haben zur Folge, dass dann Teilchen zur Erde fliegen, die wir nicht sehen können. Das sind ganz kleine, die verändern aber zum Beispiel die Eigenschaften der Erdatmosphäre. Und dann kann es passieren, dass auch mal wieder ein Beispiel, dass der GPS-Empfänger nicht mehr richtig funktioniert. Und die Elektronik, die wir hier mittlerweile am Boden haben, wird eben immer ausgereifter, aber auch immer empfindlicher. Und reagiert dann auf einmal auf so Sachen. Vor 30 Jahren war das noch kein Thema. Das liegt nicht daran, dass es da diese Protuberanzen, diese Strahlungsausbrüche auf der Sonne nicht gegeben hat. Die gab es schon immer. Aber unsere Elektronik ist mittlerweile so empfindlich, dass wir dann zum Beispiel Probleme kriegen. Dann können wir eben nicht mehr auf 10 cm genau unsere Position bestimmen, sondern nur noch auf 10 m. Das will man natürlich wissen. Deswegen haben wir also ein Programm, wo wir uns jetzt darauf vorbereiten, dass wir, wenn so ein Ausbruch auf der Sonne ist, auch mal eine Warnung rausschicken. Und wenn dann halt einer sagt, ich muss aber jetzt genau wissen, wo ich bin, dann weiß er, dass das in dem Moment vielleicht nicht funktioniert. Das war das zweite Segment. Und das dritte, das ist das, wo ich also auch für zuständig bin, hier in dem Programm. Das nennt sich Near Earth Object Segment. Auch wieder ein englisches Wort. Auf Deutsch sagt man erdnahe Asteroiden. Und diese erdnahen Asteroiden sind also jetzt nicht künstliche Objekte, sondern natürliche Objekte, so wie Kometen, die im Sonnensystem rumfliegen. Und auch da, die gibt es schon immer. Und jeder kennt wahrscheinlich diese Hypothese, dass die Dinosaurier ausgestorben sind, weil ein großer Asteroid auf die Erde eingeschlagen ist. Aber das passiert laufend. Das ist nicht nur vor Millionen Jahren passiert, sondern das passiert auch heute noch. 2008 war das im Sudan ein Objekt runter, das dann in der Atmosphäre explodiert ist. Das war noch nicht sehr groß. Wo man auch vorher im Weltraum, ganz kurz bevor es eingeschlagen ist oder auf die Erdatmosphäre getroffen ist, hat man es nur 20 Stunden vorher entdeckt. Und das möchte man eigentlich ein bisschen früher wissen. Das ist also jetzt der dritte Bereich.
Weil die machen ja nicht großaufsichtlich aufmerksam. Das sind so kleine, nicht leuchtende, nicht seltene Gücke.
Die sagen vorher nicht Bescheid. Also man muss gezielt danach suchen. Und man braucht jetzt da nicht die große Angst davor haben. Größere Objekte kennen wir alle. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn so ein kleines Objekt irgendwo, sag mal in Nordindien oder so was runterkommt, da kann das sogar militärische Konsequenzen haben.
Was ist jetzt klein in dem Kontext?
Das ist so, dass wir, klein nenne ich jetzt was, was in der Erdatmosphäre zerbricht. Und da ist so die Grenze irgendwo zwischen ein paar Meter und 30, 40 Meter. Wenn so ein Objekt in die Erdatmosphäre eintritt, wird es wahrscheinlich in der Erdatmosphäre zerbrechen und gar nicht bis zum Boden runterkommen. Da gibt es Ausnahmen. Also es gibt auch Objekte, die nur einen Meter groß sind und dann doch runterkommen und unten am Boden einen Krater schlagen. Das ist 2007 in Peru passiert. Aber groß wäre jetzt ein paar Kilometer. Der Asteroid, wo die Dinosaurier draufgegangen sind, da schätzt man, dass der so 10 Kilometer Größe gehabt hat. Da gibt es nicht so viele, die kennen wir alle. Also drei Bereiche, diese Asteroiden, Weltraumwetter und Weltraummüll.
Okay, das war schon mal ein guter Überblick. Da stellt sich mir jetzt die Frage, was heißt das jetzt konkret? Wir sollten vielleicht auch auf diese drei Teile noch mal im Detail eingehen. Aber ist SSA, was ist das jetzt konkret? Ist das so eine standortübergreifende Initiative? Wird da irgendwo ein neues Zentrum und Beobachtungszentrum gebaut? Ist das mehr so ein Netzwerk über alle Weltraumorganisationen weltweit? Was ist jetzt die Idee hinter dieser Initiative selbst?
Also SSA ist ein ESA-Programm. Das heißt, dass die ESA-Mitgliedsländer Geld dafür bereitstellen, was wir dann mit einem bisschen, was wir für unsere Gelder zum Beispiel brauchen, was wir wieder an die Mitgliedsländer verteilen. Und was wir wirklich machen mit dem Geld, das sind an und für sich ja drei Sachen. Nummer eins ist, ich habe gesagt, zum Beispiel nehmen wir wieder die Asteroiden, ich muss die entdecken erst mal, bevor ich vorhersagen kann, ob die zu Erde kommen. Das heißt, ich brauche Sensoren, ich brauche Teleskope oder auch Radarsysteme. Bei dem Weltraummüll für erdnahe Sachen sind Radarsysteme besser geeignet. Damit will ich die Objekte, die es dort oben gibt, entdecken, katalogisieren und charakterisieren. Das heißt, ein Teil, was wir mit dem Geld machen, ist, wir bauen diese Sensornetzwerke auf. Wir investieren Geld z.B. in Radarsystemen, was dann speziell für Weltraummessungen gebraucht wird. Wir investieren Geld in optische Teleskope.
Und das sind dann auch Systeme, die von der ESA auch betrieben werden?
Ja und nein. Die ESA hat die Aufgabe, das alles zu koordinieren. Und im Endeffekt läuft es so, dass wir viel über Kontrakte mit der Industrie oder auch Instituten machen, denen wir dann Geld geben und die dann so Sachen betreiben. Also Beispiel wieder Teleskop. Da haben wir eins auf Teneriffa stehen, das betreiben wir selber. Das machen wir direkt. Aber dann haben wir zum Beispiel auch gerade jetzt wieder bei dem Weltraumschrott, bei dem Thema, arbeiten wir sehr viel mit existierenden Teleskopen zusammen, wo wir praktisch nur als Leistung diese Beobachtungen einkaufen. Das heißt, die werden von den Engländern betrieben oder von den Spaniern, von irgendeiner Firma oder auch von einem wissenschaftlichen Institut. Und mit denen setzen wir da einen Vertrag auf, wo wir sagen, hier, ihr kriegt so und so viel Geld, aber dafür müsst ihr uns so und so viele Beobachtungen liefern. Das ist eines der Dinge. Das zweite, das ist jetzt bei allen drei Segmenten gleich, das ist wirklich einheitlich auch. Wir brauchen für alle diese Elemente, brauchen wir dann irgendwelche Datenzentren.
Weil Beobachten alleine bringt einem erstmal gar nicht so viel. Da weiß man im Prinzip Bescheid, aber hat noch keine Erkenntnisse.
Genau, also Beispiel wie der Weltraummüll. Ich beobachte irgendwelche Teilchen da oben, die da im Weltraum rumfliegen. Aber das Wichtige ist ja, dann vorauszurechnen, kommt der vielleicht mal irgendwann einem unserer noch funktionierenden Satelliten nahe. Und hat die Möglichkeit, den vielleicht zu treffen und dann geht der kaputt. Das heißt, ich muss, das nennen wir Conjunction Prediction, braucht man dann. Das heißt, man muss vorherrechnen, wann irgendwelche Satelliten oder auch Satellitentrümer anderen Satelliten nahe kommen. Und dafür brauche ich im Wesentlichen Computer. Und ich brauche Leute, die wissen, wie man es macht, die die Software schreiben und die dann hinterher diese Systeme auch bedienen. Und dafür bauen wir für jedes dieser drei Segmente ein Datenzentrum auf. Und damit das politisch korrekt ist, es will ja jedes Mitgliedsland, sag mal, was vom Kuchen abhaben, sitzen die alle in verschiedenen Ländern. Wir werden das Asteroidendatenzentrum in Italien aufbauen, bei Essrin, das ist also eine ESA-Niederlassung in der Nähe von Rom. Das Space Weatherdatenzentrum kommt nach Belgien. Und die Space Debris, also dieser Weltraumschrott, das kommt nach ESAC. Das ist unsere Niederlassung in Spanien bei Madrid. Und die Deutschen kriegen auch was ab. Am ESOC in Darmstadt soll das Planungszentrum, also wo man vorbereitet, wann die Teleskope wohin gucken, das soll dann nach Deutschland kommen.
Weil dort natürlich beim ESOC auch die entsprechende Erfahrung ist für die ganze Space Operation. Das liegt ja auch nahe.
Das erste waren eben die Sensoren, also Teleskoperader, das zweite Datenzentren. Und das dritte ist schwer zu konkretisieren. Da kaufen wir nicht irgendwelche Hardware oder sowas, sondern das dritte Thema ist Standards und was wir Data Policy nennen. Also es geht viel Arbeitszeit einfach auch rein, dass man drüber nachdenkt, wie zum Beispiel verteile ich den Daten. Bei einem Asteroiden, wenn also jetzt wirklich rauskommt, da kommt ein Objekt auf uns zu, wem sage ich das denn als erstes? Also da muss man drüber nachdenken, das muss man diskutieren. Das wird im Falle der Asteroiden zum Beispiel auch bei den Vereinten Nationen besprochen, in Wien. Da war ich im Februar. Und da gibt es eine Arbeitsgruppe, die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Ich muss mir auch über Datenformate Gedanken machen. Wenn ich da so Bilder von einem Teleskop kriege, wie schaue ich mir die denn an? Da muss man also richtig drüber nachdenken. Und das ist auch ein Teil, wo wirklich viel Geld reingeht, sich über die Standardisierung, die Datenverteilung und sowas Gedanken zu machen.
Jetzt ist ja nicht so, dass nicht schon heute ins Weltall geschaut werden würde, insbesondere was so die Schrottbeobachtung betrifft. Derzeit machen das aber eigentlich nur die Amerikaner, die NASA.
Ja, also der Weltraum, diese Überwachung vom niedrigen Erdorbit und sowas, da gibt es in Amerika viele Systeme. Es gibt auch in Europa was, und zwar haben die Franzosen ein Radarsystem, was die dafür nur für diesen Zweck betreiben, also ein militärisches. Das heißt GRAV, mit V-E-R-A-V-E-S. Das steht also irgendwo mitten in Frankreich. Und alles, was drüberfliegt, bis zu einer gewissen Größe, dann natürlich irgendwann, wenn das zu klein ist, dann war es das. Aber bis zu einer gewissen Größe detektieren die da alles. Es gibt auch in Deutschland ein Radarsystem, was in der Nähe von Bonn steht. Und mit dem kann man dann gezielt einzelne Objekte angucken. Also ein bisschen was gibt es da auch schon bei uns. Und das ist auch sicher der Startpunkt, wo wir jetzt anfangen, mit den Leuten zu reden, wie macht ihr das? Können wir vielleicht zusammenarbeiten und so weiter? Bei den Asteroiden ist es auch so, dass die großen Surveys, die also jetzt regelmäßig nachts den Himmel abscannen und nach neuen Objekten suchen, hauptsächlich von der NASA finanziert werden. Ein amerikanisches Projekt. Aber auch da wieder ein bisschen was gibt es in Europa. Es gibt in Spanien eine Gruppe, die eigentlich waren das mal Amateure, aber die machen das professionell. Ich habe mir das da mal angeschaut, die also auch mit drei Teleskopen regelmäßig nachts den Himmel abscannen und nach Asteroiden suchen und auch Weltraumschrott und auch Satelliten sehen können. Aber bisher war das hauptsächlich alles amerikanisch. Und das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum wir jetzt hier so ein Programm machen wollen. Bei den Asteroiden ist es vielleicht nicht so schlimm, aber gerade bei den Satelliten ist es natürlich so, dass wir von den Amis auch nicht alles zu sehen bekommen. Also die haben da schon auch dann zwei verschiedene Kataloge. Den einen, den sie nach draußen geben, und den anderen, in dem zusätzlich noch all ihre militärischen und die russischen militärischen Satelliten und so drin stehen. Und da wollen wir uns in Europa eben auch ein bisschen Unabhängigkeit verschaffen. Dass wir sagen, wir müssen unsere eigenen Systeme haben, damit wir dann eben selber gucken können, wie schaut es denn da oben wirklich aus.
Wie weit ist jetzt dieses SSHA-Konstrukt schon gedienen?
Wir sind im Moment in einer Phase, die nennen wir Vorbereitungsphase. Und die fing eben nachdenken, 1. Januar 2009 an. Und geht bis Ende diesen Jahres, also vier Jahre. Und da war die Zielsetzung, dass wir ein Konzept ausarbeiten sollen, wie wollen wir das Programm wirklich machen. Das heißt, da haben wir viel Papier vollgeschrieben oder vollschreiben lassen von Industriefirmen, von Leuten, die wissen, wie man sowas macht. Und parallel dazu, damit man nicht bloß Papier erzeugt, haben wir sogenannte Precursor-Systeme aufgebaut, also Vorläufer-Systeme. Ich weiß nicht, was da ein gutes deutsches Wort ist.
Also zum Testen halt, um mal zu schauen.
Richtig.
Klappt das eigentlich so, wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben? Ist das der richtige Ansatz, da eine Formate auszuprobieren?
Wir benutzen Teleskope. Wir haben jetzt keine neuen Teleskope gebaut, weil wir wollen ja erst mal gucken. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel Kontrakte gemacht mit, zum Beispiel, was ich gerade erwähnt habe, diesen Spaniern, die da auch Asteroidensurveys machen, Asteroidenüberwachung. Und da haben wir uns praktisch eingekauft sozusagen und haben mal eine Zeit lang mit denen zusammengearbeitet, um auch Erfahrung zu kriegen. Und mit diesem Precursor-System sind wir jetzt kurz vor der Veröffentlichung. Also das soll alles über das Internet gehen natürlich. Es wird dann halt einfach irgendwo eine Website geben, wo man hingehen kann. Und da sieht man dann zum Beispiel, aha, welche Satelliten haben die denn jetzt da beobachtet? Wo fliegen denn die Asteroiden rum? Und das muss bis Ende des Jahres müssen wir da natürlich was vorzeigen können. Auch damit wir den Geldgebern das gegenüber rechtfertigen können. Und da sind wir kurz davor. Also wir sind jetzt bei dem Asteroidensegment wieder, wo ich am meisten darüber erzählen kann, weil ich da halt direkt involviert bin. Es ist so, dass wir jetzt interne Webseiten haben, wo ich selber schon sehe, wie das ausschaut. Und die werden gerade iteriert wieder mit der Industrie, die das dann wirklich macht. Und im Juni gibt es dann ein offizielles Review, wo wir uns Experten einladen, die dann sagen sollen, was man da noch anders machen muss. Und Ende des Jahres hoffen wir dann, dass wir mit dem System rauskommen können an die Öffentlichkeit.
Was ist dann die nächste Phase? Wird dann schon alles implementiert?
Die nächste Phase, ja, da war eigentlich natürlich vorgesehen, jetzt wenn ich weiß, was ich will, und wir wissen jetzt, was wir wollen, jedenfalls steht das in den Dokumenten drin, dann fange ich an zu implementieren. Aber wir leiden natürlich auch so ein bisschen unter der Krise noch, die da vor so ein paar Jahren war und bei uns jetzt auch immer noch, dass die Leute sich noch nicht so richtig trauen, jetzt auf einem Schlag viel Geld zu investieren. Und deswegen werden wir jetzt nicht gleich voll einsteigen, sondern wir werden Ende des Jahres bei einem Meeting, wo die Vertreter der Regierungen der ESA erzählen, was wir zu machen haben, da wird Folgendes vorgestellt, dass wir noch mal vier Jahre einen sogenannten Pre-Operational-Phase haben. Es traute sich noch keiner, richtig voll einzusteigen. Das ist dann für vier Jahre vorgesehen. Damit man auch weiß, was das in Kosten bedeutet, werden wir 130-140 Millionen Euro beantragen für diese vier Jahre, die dann von den Mitgliedsländern aufgebracht werden sollen. Da soll dann aber konkret neue Teleskope gebaut und in Betrieb genommen werden. Wir werden diese Datenzentren weiterentwickeln. Wir gehen davon aus, dass das weiterlaufen wird. Wir fangen jetzt an, das zu implementieren.
Aber es gibt noch nicht unbedingt Vollgas, sondern die wichtigsten Dinge.
Man hat dann nicht fünf Teleskope, die man eigentlich bräuchte, um den ganzen Himmel abzuscannen. Sondern nur eins, und dann kann man halt nur 20 Prozent machen. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Schritt weiter dann.
Ich verstehe gut das Argument, dass man sagt, wir wollen natürlich unabhängig sein, und wir wollen unseren eigenen Blick auf diese Situation haben. Nichtsdestotrotz ist ja SSA aber auch schon als globale Dienstleistung gedacht. Es wird ja jetzt nicht nur die ESA davon profitieren, sondern üblicherweise wird das dann auch von anderen Raumfahrtorganisationen als Dienstleistung mit in Anspruch genommen. Aber abgesehen von der Eigenständigkeit sind auch andere technische Ziele. Was jetzt die Genauigkeit, den Umfang, etc. betrifft, die jetzt so die Arbeit der bisher Daten lieferenden Gruppen, wie zum Beispiel der NASA, in irgendeiner Form dann noch erweitern, verbessern?
Klar, also das ist richtig. Die Unabhängigkeit ist eine Sache, aber trotzdem sind wir natürlich in ein internationales System eingebettet. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt bei den drei Segmenten überall so ein bisschen anders. Im Gegensatz zu dem, was ich vorhin erzählt habe, wo eigentlich rauskam, dass es wirklich Sinn macht, dass das jetzt ein System wird im Ende. Bei diesem Thema unterscheiden wir uns ein bisschen. Beispiel wieder Weltraumschrott und Satelliten. Da glaube ich, ist wirklich der Vordergrund diese Unabhängigkeit der Europäer. Dass wir sagen, wir möchten wirklich selber die Möglichkeit haben, alles zu sehen, was da oben ist und nicht auf Amerikaner oder Russen oder wer auch immer das macht, angewiesen zu sein. Also ich glaube, da wird man eigentlich viel auch duplizieren von dem, was die sowieso machen.
Aber damit schafft man ja auch Redundanz.
Ja, und da kommt natürlich auch noch was anderes dazu. Die Amerikaner haben Radarsysteme nicht nur auf amerikanischem Grund und Boden, aber trotzdem, wenn wir in Europa jetzt auch so ein System haben, dann ergänzen die sich natürlich in gewissem Sinne schon. Wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Objekt habe, was in einem wirklich niedrigen Erdumlaufbahn ist, dann fliegt das in anderthalb Stunden oder noch kürzer einmal um die Erde rum. Da kann das aber schon mal sein, dass ich im richtigen Moment überhaupt hingucken muss, um das zu sehen. Und der richtige Moment hängt dann davon ab, wo ich auf der Erde bin. Wenn ich in Amerika bin, sehe ich das Objekt vielleicht gar nicht, wenn es finster ist, sondern sehe es nur am Tag oder so was. Also ergänzen tun die sich ein bisschen schon auch. Bei den Asteroiden arbeiten wir eigentlich ganz anders. Da wollen wir möglichst offen sein, möglichst international, weil so ein Asteroid sucht sich das nicht aus, in welchem Land er runterfällt. Das ist also wirklich ein weltweites Problem. Und da haben wir also ganz stark die Philosophie, dass wir mit gerade den Amerikanern eng zusammenarbeiten. Das tun wir jetzt schon. Ich treffe mich also da mit den Kollegen von der NASA regelmäßig und wir koordinieren uns wieder mit dieser Weltraumüberwachung, diese Surveys. Die Amerikaner betreiben Teleskope, wo sie nach Objekten gucken, die auch sehr weit weg sein können. Und die scannen dann einmal in der Woche den ganzen Himmel ab. Und dann sehen die Objekte, die weit weg sind, klein sind, groß sind, alles Mögliche. Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen, wie du das vorhin richtig formuliert hast, wir wollen das ergänzen. Wir wollen da jetzt nicht dasselbe noch mal machen oder Konkurrenz, sondern wir wollen was ergänzen. Und unser Surveysystem, was wir bis jetzt eben nur auf dem Papier geplant haben, das hat sich zur Zielsetzung gemacht, dass wir die Erdnahen, also die wirklich nahe an der Erde sind, dass wir uns die Objekte anschauen. Und zwar, dass wir praktisch alle Objekte, die so groß sind, wie das, was damals in Sibirien eingeschlagen ist, dieses Tunguska-Objekt, das ist auch vielen Leuten bekannt, 1908 in Sibirien.
Der erste Event, der so halbwegs berichtet wurde, da gibt es zwar keine Bilder, aber zumindest viele Augenzeugen, die da Bericht abgelegt haben.
Unser Requirement ist, wir wollen Objekte in dieser Größe drei Wochen, bevor sie der Erde wirklich nahe kommen, sehen. Das ist also eine ganz andere Zielsetzung als diese amerikanischen Surveys, die praktisch sagen, wir wollen einfach nur den ganzen Himmel mit möglichst großen Teleskopen absuchen. Bei uns ist es dann wichtiger, gar nicht die Größe des Teleskops, weil da so ein Objekt ist dann ja schon relativ nahe, das heißt, da kann man es leichter sehen, sondern wichtig ist, dass wir den ganzen Himmel einmal in der Nacht abscannen. Das kann bisher noch keiner. Also da, würde ich sagen, sind die Systeme, die die Amerikaner schon haben und das, was wir hoffentlich kriegen werden in vier, fünf Jahren, die sind sehr ergänzend, die passen dann gut zusammen.
Wie weit kann man denn da blicken?
Also diese drei Wochen Vorwarnzeit, das entspricht, muss ich nochmal eben nachdenken, das entspricht so was wie zwei Millionen, nee, weiß ich nicht mehr, mal eben kopfrechnen hier. Also so ein Objekt kommt typischerweise mit 20 Kilometer pro Sekunde, ja, pro Sekunde ist also richtig schnell, fliegt das da so auf uns zu. Und die drei Wochen habe ich jetzt im Kopf, jetzt müsste man wissen, wie viele Sekunden in drei Wochen sind. Ein Tag hat ungefähr 100.000 Sekunden, dann sagen wir mal, es sind 20 Tage. 20.000 mal 100.000, das sind zwei Milliarden, okay, nee, ich kann es nicht im Kopf. Gut, dann müssen wir eben aufs Internet warten.
Ja, ich frage mal die allwissende Müllhalde.
Genau, also einfach mal 20 Kilometer mal drei Wochen und dann in Sekunden.
Also in Sekunden sind es 30.000 Minuten, 1,8 mal 10 noch 6 Sekunden, 21 Tage.
Gut, und dann nehmen wir an, der fliegt mit 20 Kilometer pro Sekunde, dann sind das also 1,8 Millionen sind das dann von den Sekunden, mal 20 und dann haben wir es in Kilometer.
Mal gucken, ob ich gerade ganz voll bin und frage hier einfach mal Wolfram Alfa.
Also es sind ungefähr 40 Millionen. Na, da fehlen noch drei Nullen.
20 Meter pro Sekunde, Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Ja, da fehlen einfach drei Nullen. Dann sind das 36 Millionen Kilometer. Das heißt, zur Sonne sind es 150 Millionen Kilometer. Das ist also ungefähr ein Viertel der Sonnenentfernung. Also ein Viertel Sonnenentfernung. Das ist schon ein ganz schönes Stück und schon weit. Aber die Asteroiden, die der Erde nicht nahe kommen, die meisten befinden sich irgendwo zwischen Mars und Jupiter-Bahn. Und die sind dann zwei-mal, dreimal so weit weg von der Sonne wie wir. Also da ist ein Viertel, im Sonnensystem gesehen, ein Viertel Abstand Erde-Sonne ist eigentlich schon relativ nahe. Und das wollen wir sehen können, und dann ist das Objekt 40 Meter groß.
Wie viele Objekte wird man denn da wohl normalerweise sehen? Also wenn man jetzt wirklich so weit raus schaut, wie voll ist es denn da?
Also wir schätzen, das haben wir natürlich mal simuliert, wir schätzen, dass wir dann jede Woche ein so ein Objekt entdecken sollten am Anfang. Irgendwann haben wir natürlich dann alle gesehen. Also das lässt dann nach zwei, drei Jahren oder so was lässt das dann nach. Da hoffen wir dann, dass wir praktisch 80 Prozent gesehen haben. Das ist also so eine Vorstellung.
Okay, also es ist jetzt nicht gerade, dass es sich da drängelt, da draußen von solchen Objekten, aber es ist auf jeden Fall was da.
Ja, genau. Also es ist, sagen wir mal so, es ist genug da, um dass ich guten Gewissens sagen kann, mein Job ist gerechtfertigt und ist jetzt nicht total unnütz. Und das machen wir nur, weil ich jetzt meinen Gehalt kriegen will. Sondern es ist wirklich schon eine Bedrohung, die oder eine Gefahr da, dass da irgendwas passiert, die man nicht vernachlässigen kann. Sie ist nicht sehr groß, aber es lohnt sich, darüber Gedanken zu machen.
Ja, wir haben ja auch schon mal darüber Gedanken gemacht. Da lohnt sich jetzt auch noch mal ein Querverweis zu machen, und zwar auf das Gespräch Nummer neun hier über Raumzeit, über Asteroiden und Kometen im Allgemeinen und im Besonderen, wo wir dann auch mal so diesen Problempfeil erdnah Asteroiden, insbesondere natürlich der größeren, bekannten Asteroiden, diskutiert haben und eben die möglichen Konsequenzen der das Ganze haben könnte. Aber jetzt geht es ja vor allem auch darum, so ein bisschen in die Unowns vorzustoßen und eben diese Objekte, die jetzt nicht so allgemein bekannt sind, zu entdecken. Und davon ist es dann halt schon deutlich voller. Es hast du ja vorhin gesagt, 30 Meter, da brechen die noch auseinander. Da denkt man sich so, okay, alles klar, dann gibt es mal wieder so einen schönen Meteorschauer und das war's. Was ja irgendwie angedeutet, das sei dann militärisch unter Umständen schon ein Problem. Gemeinhin wird ja immer so das Szenario, oh Gott, jetzt fällt uns der Asteroid auf den Kopf und nach den Dinosauriern kommen wir als Szenario an die Wand gemalt. Was ist jetzt so schlimm an diesen 30 Metern Objekten, die da so ein bisschen Feuerwerk veranstalten?
Gut, das war jetzt der Hinweis mit dem Militär, dass wir also die Sorge eigentlich haben, dass so ein Asteroid, wenn der dann runterkommt, dann sieht man da ein Licht am Himmel, dass die Leute meinen, da kommt einer mit seiner Bodenrakete und beschießt mich jetzt. Das ist also durchaus ernsthaft diskutiert worden. Und dann muss man natürlich auch dazu sagen, diese 30 Meter, dass die auseinanderbrechen in der Atmosphäre, das ist auch nicht gottgegeben. Es war 2007 ein Fall in Peru, wo ein Objekt von nur einem Meter Größe wirklich auf dem Boden eingeschlagen ist und dort einen Krater gemacht hat. Der war dann 14 Meter groß. Und das war nun Gott sei Dank irgendwo da in diesem Hochplateau da in Peru, wo nicht viele Leute leben.
War der ein Meter, als er in die Atmosphäre eingetaucht ist, oder ist das das, was davon übrig geblieben ist?
Das ist das, was unten ankam und wie viel der jetzt dann größer war vorher, genau weiß ich es auch nicht, dann wird er vielleicht anderthalb oder zwei Meter gewesen sein. Natürlich verliert der Material, wenn er durchfliegt. Aber der ist eben nicht auseinandergebrochen und das war aber auch ein ganz normaler Stein-Meteorit dann am Ende. Also wenn das jetzt so ein fester Eisenklumpen gewesen wäre, hätte man sich das ja noch sogar erklären können. Aber das war ein ganz normales Material, wie ein Gestein auf der Erde. Und da hat man vorher gemeint, der kommt nie bis zum Boden und 2007 ist es doch passiert.
Man hat es von genau diesem Objekt, das man schon kannte, gemeint oder von allgemein dieser Kategorie?
Genau, also von allgemeinen Objekten. Wenn man so irgendeinen Wissenschaftler, der sich halt mit dem Thema beschäftigt, vor dem Jahr 2007 gefragt hätte, machst du dir Sorgen, dass ein 1-Meter-Objekt auf dem Boden runter ankommt, dann sagen die, das kann überhaupt nicht sein, wir haben das alles durchgerechnet. Und zwar haben die durchgerechnet, dass unter 30 oder 40 Metern das eigentlich in der Atmosphäre explodieren muss. Jetzt ist es aber 2007 doch passiert und es gibt jetzt natürlich die Wissenschaftler, die rechnen das jetzt neu nach. Aber so richtig ganz klar ist es mir noch nicht, was wir eigentlich früher immer falsch gerechnet haben. Aber irgendwas war da falsch, weil manchmal kommt eben so ein kleines Objekt doch runter. Auch da wieder die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der jetzt aufs Meer fällt oder in der Wüste landet, ist natürlich größer, als dass er irgendwo auf eine Stadt trifft. Trotzdem möchte ich das gerne vorher wissen. Wenn jetzt halt doch einer kommt und der kommt dann in München runter oder in Berlin, dann wäre es ja schön, wenn man da vorher mal kurz Bescheid gesagt bekommen.
Was für Faktoren spielen da noch eine Rolle? Eintrittswinkel?
Die Annahme dort war jetzt eigentlich, dass wohl der Eintrittswinkel ziemlich flach gewesen ist und dann wird er sozusagen sanft abgebremst.
So wie so ein kleiner Flitzestein, den man so über das Wasser wirft.
Richtig. Es gibt ja auch manche, die dann wirklich wieder weggehen von der Erde und gar nicht runterkommen und bei dem wäre das muss so ein Grenzfall gewesen sein. Das ist so im Moment wohl eine der Erklärungen oder aber auch, dass man einfach bei diesen ganzen Modellieren, das ist ja kompliziert. Das ist über Schall und mit Schockwellen und so. Also das ist schon kompliziert und da kann man auch einfach vielleicht irgendwelche Feinheiten, die es da gibt, die wir noch nicht richtig verstanden haben. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Ja und wie angenommen das mit dem SSA wird jetzt so umgesetzt, wie man sich das so vorstellt? Dieses Objekt hätte dann auch drei Wochen vorher schon entdeckt werden können, in der Größe?
Das ist natürlich jetzt noch eine Ecke kleiner dann. Also da muss es dann näher dran sein. Das heißt, das hätten wir dann auch vielleicht erst zwei, drei Tage vorher entdeckt oder vielleicht auch erst einen Tag.
Und würde dann diese Information der Entdeckung schon ausreichen, um eine halbwegs nachvollziehbare Aussage zu machen, wann und wo es auftrifft?
Also im Normalfall kann man, wenn man das jetzt drei Wochen vorher entdeckt, zumindest so ein Korridor angeben, wo das runterkommt. Und das ist natürlich so. Dafür haben wir dann diese Datenzentren, die wir vorhin erwähnt haben. Die sind dann natürlich in Alarmbereitschaft, wenn wirklich so ein Objekt entdeckt wird, und machen kontinuierlich Updates von ihren Vorhersagen. Ich habe vorhin dieses Objekt vom Sudan erwähnt. Da komme ich jetzt noch mal drauf zurück. Dieser Sudan-Event, wie wir den nennen, das Sudan-Ereignis. Da ist das erste Mal, dass man ein Objekt entdeckt hat, bevor es wirklich in die Erdatmosphäre eingetreten ist. Wir haben das 20 Stunden vorher entdeckt. Und da kamen also nach den ersten Rechnungen raus, der wird einschlagen. Das war kein Zweifel. Ich kann mich nicht mehr genauer erinnern, aber ich habe mal einen Plot gesehen, wo die vorhergesagt haben, wo der runterkommt. Das war 2.000, 3.000 Kilometer, ein Korridor irgendwo in Afrika. Nach 15 Stunden vor dem Einschlag war der Korridor nur noch halb so groß. Dann hat man den weiterverfolgt. Bis ungefähr 10 Stunden vor dem Einschlag war er nicht mehr genau. Dann ist er in den Erdschatten eingetreten. Dann konnte man nicht mehr sehen. Da wusste man eigentlich schon ziemlich genau, wo er runterkam. Das konnte man dann auf ein paar Kilometer vorhersagen.
Und so war es dann auch?
Das ist dann auch so gewesen, ja.
Konnte man das dann auch noch beobachten, das Event?
Da war irgendeiner, dem bin ich bis heute dankbar, der war so schlau, dass er den Meteo-Satelliten, der immer die Erde anguckt und nach Wolken sucht, dass er den so getimet hat, dass er genau im richtigen Moment, in dem Bereich, wo der Einschlag vorher gesagt war, über den Sudan scannt. Und es gibt also eine Beobachtung von dem Meteo-Satelliten.
Ist das ein Radar?
Nee, das ist ein optischer. Ich glaube, es war ein Infraroten oder so. Also ich kann mir an so ein Falschfarbenbild erinnern. Und der macht aber nicht immer Bilder von der ganzen Erde, sondern der scannt die Erde ab und daraus setzt er dann diese Bilder zusammen, die wir dann so im Fernsehen und so was sehen. Und der muss also zum richtigen Zeitpunkt dann über den Sudan gucken, sonst hätte er es nicht gesehen. Und irgendeiner, der also diese Meteorosateliten kontrolliert, der hat geschaltet und hat das so gemacht, dass wir also tatsächlich eine Beobachtung haben von Meteorosat, von dieser Feuerkugel, die dann halt da gerade im Infraroten natürlich schön zu sehen ist. Ziemlich genau an der vorhergerechneten Stelle.
Macht so ein Bild dann nur ein schönes Poster, oder kann man dem dann auch noch irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse rausziehen?
Also da gibt es eine Veröffentlichung, wo dann abgeschätzt wurde, wie viel Energie bei dieser Explosion freigesetzt wurde. Und das kann man dann natürlich mit der erwarteten Energie vergleichen, die wieder aus diesen Modellrechnungen rauskommt.
Das ist dann wieder schönes Futter für die Neuberechnung dieser Einschlagsenergie, verstehe ich. Ist das dann vielleicht auch so ein Ziel bei SSA oder nur so ein Nebeneffekt, dass man eben auch wirklich sagt, wir bauen jetzt auch noch so die Benachrichtigung der Beobachtung auch noch mit rein? Dass also Satellitenbetreiber vielleicht für den SOM-Fall, Beobachtungssatelliten vor allem, diese Informationen auch so mundgerecht bekommen, dass sie dann auf so etwas umschalten können?
Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Ziel bei dem SSA-Projekt. Das ist also kein wissenschaftliches Programm. Das läuft auch bei uns nicht in der Wissenschaftsabteilung, obwohl ich selber Wissenschaftler bin, aber es läuft in der Operations-Abteilung. Die Idee ist in der Tat, dass wir einen Service zur Verfügung stellen. Auch wieder, der ist unterschiedlich für die verschiedenen Bereiche, aber bei den Asteroiden wird das so sein, dass eigentlich alle Informationen frei ist. Dass wir aber eben auch mit unseren politischen Ansprechpartnern reden und sagen, wollt ihr denn zum Beispiel eine gezielte Information, wenn jetzt irgendwo wirklich was vorhergesagt wird, so wie damals im Sudan. Die Amerikaner haben das ja vorhergerechnet dann und die Europäer auch. Und die Amerikaner haben so einen Informationsprozess, der schon etabliert. Also einer von der NASA wird dann informiert von den Leuten, die da hinter dem Rechner sitzen und sagen, da kommt jetzt was. Der ist also immer 24 Stunden rund um die Uhr über Mobiltelefonen erreichbar. Der ist angerufen worden, der hat einen Ansprechpartner im US State Department und die haben dann über politische Kanäle den Sudan informiert und gesagt, Leute, da kommt was, ist eben keine böse Rakete, sondern ist nur ein Asteroid. In Europa sind wir noch nicht so weit, da bauen wir diese Methoden gerade erst auf. Aber das ist ganz klar eine der Zielsetzungen, gerade bei Weltraumwetter zum Beispiel. Da wollen vielleicht Betreiber von einer Elektrizitätszentrale, die also da empfindlich sein können gegen so Sonnenstürme und sowas, die wollen vielleicht auch andere Informationen haben als einer, der jetzt da oben Satelliten betreibt. Und da wird also gezielt dran gearbeitet, auch in Gesprächen mit den zukünftigen Kunden sozusagen. Was wollte er eigentlich haben? Das ist eine der Kernpunkte eigentlich auch dieses Systems. Wie verteile ich die Informationen? Das müssen wir natürlich alles noch genau definieren, aber das ist eine der Aufgaben, wo wir gerade mit beschäftigt sind.
Das heißt, SSA ist jetzt auch gar nicht mal nur ein System, das jetzt nur für die Raumfahrt von Relevanz ist. Also abgesehen jetzt von dem, es ist keine böse Raketewarnung, was potenziell dann vielleicht mal einen Konflikt, zumindest ein bisschen eindämmen kann oder verhindern kann. Wer könnte denn noch Interesse haben an diesen Daten?
Ja, also ein schönes Beispiel glaube ich ist jetzt dieses Thema Weltraumwetter, wo ich selber überrascht war, wie ich von meinem Kollegen, der da zuständig ist, mal so einen Übersichtsvortrag gehört habe, wo das Weltraumwetter eine Rolle spielt. Da gehört zum Beispiel dazu, ich habe das vorhin erwähnt, es geht immer um diese Teilchen, die von der Sonne kommen, irgendwelche kleinen Sonnenwind. Wenn ich da irgendwo in Norwegen bin, dann sieht man diese tollen Polarlichter. Da sieht man also, dass die mit der Atmosphäre wechselwirken. Da passiert irgendwas.
Die Aurora Borealis von dem Magnetfeld zu den Polen gelingt.
Das kann man da oben sehen, aber die Effekte gibt es auch am Boden. Eine der Sachen, die ich vorhin überhaupt nicht wusste, ist, dass zum Beispiel Ölfirmen sich für sowas interessieren, weil Pipelines lange metallene Rohre haben. Durch diesen Effekt können da Ströme induziert werden in der Pipeline. Da kann es passieren, dass die Pipeline beschädigt wird. Das war mir total neu, dass es da so Effekte gibt. Transformator-Stationen werden dadurch beeinflusst durch diese Effekte, die in der Atmosphäre entstehen. Das heißt, auch Elektrizitätsfirmen sind da sehr interessiert dran. Gerade weil unsere Elektronik immer empfindlicher wird, wird die dann durch so etwas beeinflusst. Dann kann man alles abschirmen, aber das kostet halt Geld. Das sind zwei typische Beispiele, die vielleicht gar nicht so offensichtlich sind.
Sind das jetzt theoretische Erwägungen oder ist das auch schon nachgewiesen worden?
Das ist schon passiert. Ich habe Fotos gesehen, zum Beispiel von einem Transformatorhäuschen, wo halt was explodiert ist mehr oder weniger, weil irgendwas da drin passiert ist, was aufgrund des Weltraumwetters entstanden ist. Details weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber das sind so die Effekte, die man da ein bisschen berücksichtigen muss.
Das heißt, wenn man das rechtzeitig weiß, könnte man die Transformatorhäuschen ein bisschen runterfahren oder mal ausschalten oder sonst irgendwas machen?
Ganz genau, das ist dann die Idee. Dann kurz ausschalten und dann ist da kein Problem. Und so ist halt was kaputt gegangen. Gut, bei den Pipelines weiß ich nicht, was man macht. Da muss man vielleicht dann die Rohre nicht mehr aus Metall machen oder aus keine Ahnung. Also da bin ich ja nun auch nicht der Experte.
Da müssen Sie sich halt was einfallen lassen.
Dann habe ich Navigationssysteme, habe ich schon erwähnt. Also wenn ich halt so einen GPS-Empfänger habe, dann kann es passieren, dass der nicht mehr so gut geht. Das ist relevant, wenn ich jetzt auch bei Galileo dann mit diesem Navigationssystem eine Genauigkeit bekomme, dass ich praktisch weiß, auf welcher Fahrbahnspur ich mit meinem Auto fahre. Und da muss man dann schon überlegen, kann ich diese Geräte so sicher bauen, dass selbst wenn ich so einen Sonnensturm oder so etwas habe, dass ich dann trotzdem noch diese Genauigkeit erreiche. Weil das ist natürlich fatal, wenn das dann nicht mehr funktioniert. Wenn ich mich jetzt also drauf verlasse, auf mein Navigationssystem, und dann kann das zu Unfällen führen, wenn das nicht mehr richtig geht.
Und es sind ja nicht nur Autos, wo man ja auch immer noch lenken und gucken kann. Aber es ist ja auch so automatische Andock-Prozeduren von Schiffen, in Häfen, etc. davon betroffen. Ja genau, auf engen Flughäfen insbesondere.
Stimmt, mit dem Auto ist vielleicht, da sind wir noch nicht so weit, dass die von alleine fahren.
Gut, aber solche Gedankenspiele gibt es ja sehr wohl. Beziehungsweise die Technik an sich ist ja da, dass Autos im Prinzip ja auch alleine fahren könnten. Nur will das wahrscheinlich auch, zumindest vorerst keiner. Das wird sich zeigen. Vielleicht bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Weltraumwetter, weil das auch so ein Thema ist, was hier noch nicht so viel befasst wird. Ich weiß, das ist jetzt auch nicht dein Spezialgebiet, aber das spielt schon auch eine große Rolle. Das kam jetzt hier auch häufiger mal zur Sprache bei Missionen. Gerade natürlich die Fernerkundungsmissionen zunehmend davon abhängig sind. Die Frage ist, wie misst man das jetzt eigentlich? Weil man hat ja jetzt keine Sensoren auf der Sonne. Man hat vielleicht Beobachtungsmissionen, die mit einbezogen werden. Was spielt da alles mit rein? Woher weiß man, dass da was zu erwarten ist?
Also das ist ein Kollege, der sitzt hier bloß zwei Zimmer weiter. Der beschäftigt sich mit einer Mission, die heißt Proba 2. Weil das halt die zweite Mission der Proba-Reihe ist. Und Proba ist eine Abkürzung, das ist irgendwas mit Technologie. Und da gibt es eine Mission, diese Proba-2-Mission. Die hat ein Teleskop an Bord. Das ist also ein Satellit, der um die Erde rumfliegt und permanent die Sonne anschaut mit diesem Teleskop. Und die können so was vorhersagen. Die beobachten rund um die Uhr die Sonne. Die haben zum Beispiel auch, also die machen Bilder in, ich glaube, in Ultravioletten oder irgendwas. Und die haben einfach nur ein Gerät an Bord, was sehr genau die Strahlungsintensität, die von der Sonne kommt, also auf Deutsch, wie hell ist die Sonne, das misst der ganz genau. Und an diesem Ding, wenn eben jetzt so eine Protobaranz, also so eine Eruption auf der Sonne ist, dann sieht man das in diesem einen Messwert. Da geht dann einfach das Signal so ein bisschen hoch. Und das kann man praktisch automatisieren und kann sagen, sobald das über einen bestimmten Grenzwert geht, schick mir eine E-Mail auf mein Handy oder sowas. Und dann weiß der Kollege, der heißt Joe, dann weiß der genau, da ist jetzt gerade was auf der Sonne passiert. Und dann wissen wir jetzt von früheren Beobachtungen, dass dann eben nach einer bestimmten Zeit diese Strahlung bei uns an der Erde dann ankommt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie schnell das ist, aber das geht nicht mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Die brauchen ein paar Minuten oder sogar länger. Und dann könnte ich praktisch, zugegebenermaßen sehr kurzfristig, aber doch eine Warnung geben. Und wenn ich jetzt meinetwegen Satellitenbetreiber auch gleichzeitig bin, so wie wir bei der ESOC in Darmstadt da Satelliten betreiben, dann könnten wir uns sehr leichten Systemen vorstellen, wo wir jetzt mit diesem einen Signal von diesem einen Sensor von Proba 2 eben eine Warnung geben an die Betreiber von den Satelliten in Darmstadt und sagen, oh Achtung, da kommt gleich was. Und dann hätten die vielleicht irgendeine Notfallprozedur, wo sie dann wieder was abschalten können, damit nichts kaputt geht.
Also wenn da jetzt erstmal noch jemand eine E-Mail lesen muss, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass da wichtige Zeit vertan wird. Aber im Prinzip denkt man hier über eine vollständige Automatisierung dieses Prozesses nach.
Ja, da muss man mal aufpassen. Das weiß ich nicht, wie weit man da wirklich gehen kann. Also so ein Satellit zu betreiben, da ist noch viel Menschenentscheidung mit drin. Man möchte da, manche Sachen kann man natürlich automatisieren. Aber sowas würde ich jetzt im Moment erstmal doch lieber die E-Mail lesen und dann nochmal selber überlegen, ob ich ausschalte. Und erst wenn ich das dann wirklich begriffen habe, was passiert, dann kann man das automatisieren. Aber es stimmt schon, im Endeffekt sollte man sowas automatisch machen, weil sonst ist man nicht schnell genug. Das ist richtig.
Vor zwei Wochen war doch irgendwie so ein größerer Sonnensturm. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht habe ich was falsch mitbekommen. Das Gefühl, dass da so ein bisschen früher schon darüber sinniert wurde, dass dann in den nächsten Tagen Auswirkungen zu befürchten seien. Also was für Zeiträume vergehen denn von einer ersten Detektion bis zu... Wie lange wirkt sich das dann aus?
Also wenn ich auf der Sonne so einen Ausbruch habe, dann dauert es eben eine bestimmte Zeit, bis das bei uns ankommt. Wie gesagt, ich habe die Zahl vergessen. Das waren irgendwie Minuten oder war es auch eine Stunde.
Aber es hält dann auch eine Weile an.
Und das ist richtig. Das ist ja praktisch ein steiler Anstieg dann. Und dann geht das so langsam wieder zurück, weil das halt so auf der Sonne entsteht.
Sind das dann auch Minuten oder sind das Tage?
Nein, das sind auch Minuten oder einige zehn Minuten oder so. Tage sind es nicht. Nee, so lange nicht.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die Meldung eigentlich in der Zeitung steht, ist es eigentlich schon wieder vorbei?
Normalerweise ja. Die Frage nach, kann ich das denn vorhersagen? Also was wir wissen, ist, dass diese Ausbrüche auf der Sonne geknüpft oder gekoppelt sind an große Sonnenflecken. Und Sonnenflecken, die sehe ich, und da die Sonne dreht sich, die braucht irgendwie, ich glaube, 28 Tage dreht die sich einmal. Und da kann es sein, wenn ich jetzt am Rand der Sonne einen Sonnenfleck ankommen sehe, dann kann ich sagen, oh, das ist ein riesen Sonnenfleck, das schaut nach einer aktiven Gegend aus. Da kann es jetzt passieren, dass irgendwann, wenn das sich in unsere Richtung gedreht hat, weil das geht ja nur in eine Richtung raus, wenn sich das dann in unsere Richtung gedreht hat, dass wir dann auf der Erde Probleme kriegen. Also man kann Sachen vorhersagen in dem Sinne, dass wenn ich da so eine große Sonnenfleckengruppe oder einen großen Fleck sehe und ich weiß, das ist eine aktive Gegend, die sehe ich aber erst mal am Sonnenrand. Und eigentlich erst wenn die so in unsere Richtung zeigt, dann macht uns das wirklich was aus. Wenn man das in die andere Richtung bläst, dann macht uns das ja nichts.
Das heißt, man könnte im Prinzip, 28 Tage dreht sich das Ding? Also ist dann so eine Woche vorher maximal, die man jetzt irgendwas wirklich erahnen kann und alles andere liegt, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, im unklaren Bereich. Oder halten sich diese Sonnenflecken dann auch über mehrere Monate?
Das ist mehr so zwei, drei Sonnenrotationen passiert, dass man denselben Fleck sieht. Also ich habe früher, als ich jünger war, habe ich da immer noch als Hobby die Sonne angeguckt und gezeichnet. Und da weiß ich noch, da kann man richtig zuschauen, wie die sich auch verändern, von einem Tag zum nächsten zum Teil. Aber ich würde sagen, mehr als einen Monat macht so eine Sonnenfleckengruppe eigentlich normalerweise nicht.
Das heißt, wenn man einmal wirklich eine starke Eruption gehabt hat, kann das durchaus sein, dass so ein Monat danach es nochmal nachwabert.
Aber meistens ist dann schon wieder was anderes los auf der Sonne. Also das ändert sich dadurch in dem Zeitraum.
Was ja so in den Medien dann immer so der Klassiker ist, ist so, ja, unsere Mobilfunknetze fangen an zu schmelzen etc., die übliche Übertreibung. Inwiefern sind denn Einfluss auf solche Systeme auch realistisch?
Muss ich zugeben, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, weiß ich nicht. Also wird sicher auch einen Einfluss haben mit eben hier diese ganzen Antennen und so, die da die Signale rausschicken. Das ist ähnlich wie bei dem GPS, nehme ich an. Aber ehrlich gesagt, da weiß ich auch keine Details.
Aber so tendenziell kann man schon davon ausgehen, dadurch, dass wir so eine zunehmende Miniaturisierung auf der einen Seite haben, was jetzt die Elektronik betrifft, womit natürlich die ganzen Toleranzen dann auch geringer werden, als auch, was ja auch in der Raumfahrt ein Trend ist, der Trend hin, höhere Frequenzen zur Transmission zu nutzen, wird es potentiell alles noch anfälliger werden.
Ja, das ist genau richtig. Also wir müssen da schon aufpassen. Ein gutes Beispiel, wie man was baut, was nicht empfindlich ist, das kann ich mich auch von früher erinnern, das stand zumindest vor 30 Jahren schon im Deutschen Museum. Da ist nämlich der Ringkernspeicher der deutschen Helios-Raumsonde zu bewundern gewesen. Und das ist also ein Speicherelement für den Computer gewesen. Und die hatten früher Magnetringe, also richtig so wie so Ohrringe so groß. Und dann gingen so Drähte durch und die wurden magnetisiert und entmagnetisiert. Genau. Und das Teil, da macht das nichts, wenn irgendein kosmisches Teilchen da so einen Kupferring trifft. Aber heutzutage ist halt so ein Speicherchip, wie man ihn im Computer hat, ist unendlich kleine Zellen, irgendwas mit Silizium. Und wenn da eben ein Proton einschlägt, dann passiert da schon irgendwas.
Das ist ja auch ein Dauerproblem im All. Dass ja die Elektronik dort auch einfach ganz anderen Bedingungen ausgesetzt ist als hier unten an der Erde. Weil halt nicht eine schützende Atmosphäre da drüber liegt. Auch da erinnere ich mich spontan an eine andere Raumzeit-Episode, wo das ein Thema war, nämlich da, wo es um Robotik in der Raumfahrt ging, was ja auch zu meiner Überraschung durchaus noch eine relativ junge Disziplin ist. Und da war das auch genauso ein Thema. Ausgabe Nummer 14 ist das, wie groß die Anforderungen sind, insbesondere für jetzt Elektronik, Steuerelektronik, die sich außerhalb der ISS zum Beispiel befindet. Gerade bei Robotern will man ja sie genau an den Stellen eigentlich einsetzen, wo es für Menschen jetzt eben nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich ist. Und so ein Spacewalk ist zwar romantisch und für jeden Astronaut und sicherlich der große Traum. Aber wenn man halt täglich raus muss, ist das eben auch extrem aufwendig und natürlich auch nochmal eine zusätzliche Belastung für die Astronauten. Aber es ist eben gar nicht so einfach, Elektronik mal so eben im Weltall dauerhaft zu betreiben. Und auch da spielt natürlich der Sonnenwind eine große Rolle. Das heißt, auch hier ist das wieder so ein Teil, wo alle anderen Missionen auch automatisch einen Vorteil davon haben. Das heißt, man weiß, in der Richtung gibt es besondere... Es ist ja auch gar nicht mal nur in Richtung Erde sozusagen. Das heißt, man erfasst eigentlich alles. Sprich auch, wenn man sagt, wir haben da jetzt gerade eine Sonde, die ist irgendwie in Richtung Mars unterwegs, befindet sich dort. Es gibt eine entsprechende Protuberanz in die Richtung. Stellt euch mal drauf ein.
Das ist richtig, ja. Ein Beispiel vielleicht, wie man eben doch diese Automatisierung, wo wir vorhin drüber geredet haben, fällt mir jetzt ein. Das gibt es auf einer unserer Raumsonden und zwar auf Rosetta. Da war ich ja involviert in der Entwicklung der Kamera, die da drauf ist, die Wissenschaftskamera. Die ist am Max-Planck-Institut für Katlenburg-Lindau. War da die Federführung oder ist noch? Und es gibt auf Rosetta auch einen Strahlungssensor. Das ist ein Gerät, wo irgendein Elektronikbauteil drin sitzt, was eben empfindlich auf diese Strahlung, die von der Sonne kommt, diese Teilchenstrahlung ist. Und da gibt es einen Modus, in dem man dieses Gerät auslesen kann, dass er diese Informationen an alle Instrumente, die auf Rosetta drauf sitzen, weiterleitet. Und wir haben in der Kamera eine Software, die wir laufen lassen könnten, wenn wir das wollen. Ich glaube, im Moment läuft die nicht. Dass wenn eben dieser Messwert über einen bestimmten Wert geht, dass man dann bei der Kamera, die Kamera erstmal ausschaltet und vor allem auch den Deckel zumacht und die Filterräder vor den Sensor fährt, weil nämlich der Sensor sehr empfindlich ist. Und einfach je mehr Material jetzt davor ist, umso mehr ist der geschützt. Also da haben wir schon so eine Automatisierung implementiert. Ob das jetzt wirklich läuft, weiß ich nicht. Oder laufen wird, das müssen wir dann sehen.
Bei solchen Fernmissionen ist ja auch wichtig, dass sie selber reagieren. Weil selbst wenn man denen jetzt Bescheid sagen wollte, die sind ja auch ganz schön weit draußen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie weit ist, wie lange bräuchte das Licht derzeit bis Rosettas auf dem Weg zum Jupiter? Das ist schon ein bisschen...
Ja, ja. Also ich glaube, wenn wir am Kometen ankommen, sind wir auch so eine Sonne-Erde-Entfernung oder sowas von der Sonde weg. Vielleicht auch mehr oder ein bisschen weniger. Aber es sind viele Minuten. Und dann ist, wenn das hin und zurück geht und dann eben auch noch wieder am Boden erstmal einer eine Entscheidung treffen soll, dann wäre es natürlich schon zu spät. Aber meistens macht man das so, dass man sein Instrument schon so baut, dass es eben nicht so furchtbar empfindlich ist. Aber das widerspricht natürlich immer diesen Bedürfnissen, möglichst klein und möglichst leicht und möglichst wenig Leistung verbrauchend und sowas. Es ist immer ein Trade-off, wie man da so schön sagt.
Ist das eigentlich keine besonders wissenschaftliche Aktivität, für einen Wissenschaftler, sich mit so einem organisatorisch übergreifenden Projekt zu beschäftigen, wenn es auch sicherlich nicht arm an Herausforderungen ist? Inwiefern kann man die wissenschaftliche Arbeit an der Stelle da auch immer wieder mit einbringen? Inwiefern ist es auch erforderlich, dass Wissenschaftler an so etwas mit beschäftigt sind?
Das denke ich mal, ist auch wieder je nach Segment unterschiedlich. Ich denke mal, bei diesem Thema Weltraumschrott, da weiß man eigentlich schon relativ viel. Trotzdem gibt es wissenschaftliche Arbeiten, z.B. wie verhält sich jetzt eine schwarze Farbplatte im Gegensatz zu einer weißen. Wenn ich den Orbit vorher berechnen will, dann spielt das eine Rolle, weil diese Teilchen auch sehr klein sind und leicht. Die Teilchen werden z.B. durch den Strahlungsdruck der Sonne in ihrem Orbit verändert. Da gibt es Bereiche, die muss man auch wissenschaftlich erst noch ein bisschen besser verstehen. Aber ich glaube, in dem Thema weiß man schon relativ viel. Da sind wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich dann auch Ingenieure mit beschäftigt. Aber schon bei dem Weltraumwetter, das ist noch sehr wissenschaftlich eigentlich das Ganze. Das Projekt SSA, auch bei den Asteroiden, da geht es eigentlich nicht um die Wissenschaft, da geht es um den Service. Aber wenn ich nicht den wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund habe, dann kann ich nicht richtig vorausberechnen, wann so ein Objekt z.B. auf die Erde trifft. Oder was passiert jetzt wirklich in meinem Mobiltelefon, wenn da so ein Strahlungsausbruch auf der Sonne ist? Oder auch, was wir vorhin diskutiert haben, kann ich das vielleicht sogar vorher noch genauer vorhersagen, wann so ein Ausbruch von der Sonne kommt? Das ist wirklich nun die große Spielwiese der Wissenschaftler. Man muss die Sonne modellieren, man muss verstehen, was da abläuft. Also gerade in diesen zwei Gebieten mit dem Space Weather und den Asteroiden, glaube ich, sind wir noch sehr eng mit der Wissenschaft verknüpft. Und bei dem Space Debris, gut, da kann ich es nicht sagen. Vielleicht ist das da genauso, da habe ich nun nicht ganz so den Einblick.
Trotz alledem erscheint mir ja diese Weltraumschrott-Problematik auch diejenige, die jetzt auch den größten wirtschaftlichen Druck hat. Das ist ganz klar, die Objekte gefährden viele Missionen. Es ist ja eigentlich an der Tagesordnung, dass die ISS, ich glaube erst vor zwei, drei Wochen, gab es wieder so einen Moment, wo ausgewichen wurde, also man hat etwas vorgezogen, was man ohnehin machen wollte, die Orbit-Anhörung, aber hätte man es halt nicht gemacht, wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit größer gewesen, wieder von irgendeinem Miniatur-Objekt, und ich glaube, es war auch wieder so ein paar Zentimeter-Objekte in dem Moment getroffen zu werden. Durch die etwas nachlässige Herangehensweise früherer Missionen ist es ja wirklich ein akuter Zustand im Orbit, also nicht nur in einem Orbit, sondern eigentlich in allen Bereichen, die die Erde umgeben. Wie wichtig ist dieses Thema in der gesamten Raumfahrt-Community? Welche Rolle spielt das? Wie wichtig ist damit auch SSA?
Diese Thematik Vermeidung von Weltraumschrott ist sehr wichtig geworden, aber eben erst die letzten 10, 15 Jahre oder so. Und eigentlich hätte man damit schon eher anfangen müssen. Die Geschichte ist so, dass irgendwann, also schon vor 20 Jahren oder so, man natürlich drauf kam, wenn da mal ein Satellit aus Versehen explodiert ist, das passierte mal irgendwo, da ist irgendwas in der Treibstoffleitung nicht richtig gewesen oder so, und dann sind da die Trümmer rumgeflogen. Und da wusste man schon, oh, da müssen wir aufpassen. Aber es gab keine richtige Methode, jetzt irgendwas dagegen zu unternehmen. Seit einigen Jahren, oder ich genau weiß ich nicht, wie lange, gibt es was, das nennt sich Interagency Debris Consultancy Group, irgend sowas. Und die beschäftigt sich mit genau dieser Fragestellung, was kann ich denn tun, damit nicht noch mehr Trümmer entstehen da oben. Und das ist also auch ein Misch von Wissenschaftlern und Vertretern aller größeren Raumfahrtagenturen auf der ganzen Welt. Und diese Arbeitsgruppe, also wenn man da auch bei der ESA Mitglied ist, dann ist man offiziell von unserem obersten Chef nominiert und kann auch im Namen der ESA sprechen. Und die haben zum Beispiel über die letzten Jahre ein Handbuch geschrieben, wo drin steht, was man tun muss, um zu vermeiden, dass neuer Weltraumschrott entsteht. Da gehört zum Beispiel dazu, dass ich Treibstoffleitungen, dass ich den Treibstoff ablasse am Ende einer Mission. Und der Treibstoff selber, der ist dann grasförmig und der tut keinem was. Aber man will dadurch vermeiden, dass irgendwo eine Explosion gibt, weil jetzt die Sonne irgendwas aufheizt und dann fliegen da die Trümmer rum. Ein Beispiel, aber da gibt es viele Beispiele. In diesem Handbuch steht also drin, was man dagegen tun kann. Jetzt kommt das nächste. Alle die, die in dieser Arbeitsgruppe dabei sind, die Raumfahrt-Agenturen, die haben sich gegenseitig versprochen, dass sie diesem Handbuch auch folgen. Ich meine, das ist ja der wichtige Punkt. Aufschreiben, dass man keinen Müll auf die Straße schmeißen soll, kann man gerne. Und gut, bei uns funktioniert das, weil wenn man es doch macht und einer erwischt einen, dann muss man Strafe zahlen. Das ist im Weltraum schwieriger, weil das so mit dem Recht so ein Problem ist. Aber die, die in dieser Arbeitsgruppe sind, diese Raumfahrtbehörden, es sind 15 oder 20, weiß nicht genau, DLR ist mit dabei, die ESA ist natürlich mit dabei, die haben gesagt, wir machen das auch wirklich so. Und wenn ich jetzt hier ein neues Projekt anfange, dann steht in meinen, wir machen alles ja ganz formell mit Pflichtenheften, heißt das glaube ich auf Deutsch, ich nenne das Requirements-Dokument, da steht dann drin, was meine Mission tun können muss. Ein Requirement, was eine Anforderung, die immer drin steht, ist, du musst dem Space, diesem Handbuch, ich habe den Namen vergessen, dem musst du folgen. Das ist wichtig und das muss gemacht werden, was drin steht. Das kostet Geld, das kostet vielleicht Gewicht, weil ich irgendwo ein zusätzliches Ventil einbauen muss.
Oder mehr Treibstoff mitnehmen.
Aber das machen wir. Leider hätte man das vielleicht schon 10 Jahre vorher machen müssen, weil jetzt passiert es eben, dass trotzdem noch Satelliten zusammenstoßen. Ich meine, man kann ja auch oft, passiert ja was unabsichtlich. Die Chinesen haben da mal einen Satelliten abgeschossen, der dann auch in 1000 Trümmer zerplatzt ist. Die haben sich also nicht an dieses Abkommen gehalten. Und das passiert dann halt noch. Aber es wird zumindest daran gearbeitet. Und das zeigt auch, dass das ein ganz großes Thema ist in der Raumfahrt. Also ganz groß, ich meine. Aber es wird einfach automatisch mit eingebaut.
Ja, man merkt, also ich denke, was auch mittlerweile allen klar geworden sein dürfte, ist, also auch so eine Maßnahme wie dieses Abschießen des Satelliten, wo ja vielleicht noch so ein bisschen so die militärische Gedankenwelt im Vordergrund war, hat ja dann im Ergebnis eigentlich nur erbracht, oh, da schießen wir uns aber jetzt ins Knie, weil auch unsere eigenen Satelliten sind natürlich durch diese Trümmer bedroht. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt sagen kann, das fliegt jetzt hier nur in die amerikanischen Satelliten rein oder sowas. Das ist ja Quatsch. Und das ist eigentlich die Orientierung, die sich jetzt durchsetzt, dass man einfach sagt, okay, wir müssen da einfach mal alles schön sauber halten, weil sonst werden unsere eigenen Missionen nicht nur gefährdet, sondern eben auch teurer, weil wir wiederum noch sehr viel mehr Aufwand treiben müssen, um eben mit dem Schrott klarzukommen. Also so ist es halt jetzt auch. Wird es denn noch anderer, also ist denn jetzt auch bei anderen Weltraumorganisationen noch ähnliches in Planung wie SSA?
Die Amerikaner machen das natürlich schon lange, wobei SSA überall ein bisschen was anderes heißt. Also in Amerika ist SSA zum Beispiel nur Weltraumwetter und die Satelliten. Die Asteroiden laufen separat. Die sind halt bei der NASA. Und das restliche SSA-Programm bei den Amerikanern ist eigentlich hauptsächlich die Air Force und das State Department, die sich da mit beschäftigen. Es gibt in Russland jetzt auch was, das sich SSA nennt. Die haben sich so ein bisschen an uns dran geknüpft und haben da also auch die drei Segmente Satelliten oder Weltraumschrott und Asteroiden und Weltraumwetter. Da ist es immer ein bisschen schwierig zu hören, was die eigentlich wirklich tun. Also wenn man dann auf die entsprechenden Konferenzen geht, gibt es dann da immer einen Vortrag, ja, wir haben jetzt auch ein SSA-Programm, aber noch weiß ich nicht, was da jetzt genau passieren wird. Und eigentlich, das sind so die, die mir jetzt direkt in den Kopf kommen, wo ich weiß, dass da was passiert. In Japan gibt es sicher auch viele Aktivitäten, gerade zum Thema Asteroidenbeobachtungen. Da gibt es hauptsächlich wissenschaftliche Institute, die sich damit beschäftigen. Aber jetzt so ein großes, ob die ein großes SSA-Programm haben, weiß ich nicht.
Ist es eigentlich eine besondere Herausforderung, so behördenübergreifend zu arbeiten dann in der ESA, oder ist das eigentlich so ein bisschen der Normalfall? Also ist das SSA irgendwie noch mal eine Ausnahme, oder ist das eigentlich so in derselben Dimension wie andere Projekte und Missionen auch?
Ja, das ist eine interessante Frage. Muss ich direkt mal drüber nachdenken. Man hat natürlich immer auch bei anderen Projekten Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Ländern, anderen Raumfahrtagenturen. Auch wenn ich meine Lieblingsmission Rosetta jetzt als Beispiel nehme, da gibt es amerikanische Instrumente drauf und Wissenschaftler, die da mitarbeiten. Wir haben jetzt bei dieser Studie, die wir machen für diese Asteroiden-Rückführmission, hatten wir Diskussionen, ob wir das mit Japanern zusammen machen, ob wir das mit Amerikanern zusammen machen. Und bei SSA ist es vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr, dass man mit anderen Organisationen zusammenarbeiten muss. Jedenfalls ein bisschen mehr, als ich das aus meiner Welt von früher von den Wissenschaftsmissionen her kenne. Weil einfach so was wie die Asteroiden, die, wie ich vorhin sagte, die suchen sich nicht aus, auf welches Land die runterfallen, das kann überall passieren. Ich glaube schon, dass man da ein bisschen noch mehr offen sein muss gegenüber was Anderem machen. Aber es ist nicht die Ausnahme. Ich denke, dass wir bei allen Projekten oder bei den meisten Projekten, wo wir arbeiten, sehr viel mit anderen Organisationen zusammenarbeiten. Die Raumstationen und so weiter.
Das dachte ich mir schon. Mir kam so ein bisschen dieser Gedanke, dass man vielleicht noch mehr darüber nachdenken muss, aus was für anderen Missionen und Konstellationen könnte man vielleicht noch einen Mehrwert an Eingabedaten erhalten. Dass es nicht so offensichtlich ist wie, wir haben hier eine Mission, wir brauchen eine Kamera, da müssen wir uns jetzt mit jemanden zusammen tun, der eine Kamera hat, sondern dass man überhaupt erst mal anschaut, was gibt es denn überhaupt und was könnte eine Kombination der Ergebnisse gegebenenfalls an neuem entstehen lassen, was so vorher gar nicht existiert hat?
Das ist richtig. Es ist doch ein bisschen anders. Ein weiteres Beispiel ist natürlich auch, was dann hinten rauskommt. Wir haben ja schon ein paar Mal über diese Entscheidungsprozesse oder auch die politischen Prozesse, die dann ablaufen müssen, gesprochen. Ein Beispiel, dass SSA auf einem anderen Level arbeitet als jetzt zum Beispiel so eine Wissenschaftsmission, ist, dass wir sowas dann bei den United Nations diskutieren. Da gibt es ein Committee for Peaceful Use of Outer Space, COPURS abgekürzt, und die treffen sich immer im Februar und im Juni in Wien. Da fahre ich also regelmäßig hin. Da gibt es für die Asteroiden eine Arbeitsgruppe, die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, um dann eben auch auf diesem Level zu definieren, wie geht man denn eigentlich vor, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Entscheidung treffen müsste, um jetzt eine Abwehrmission gegen den Asteroiden zu starten. Dann wird das auf diesem Level diskutiert. Das habe ich bei einer Wissenschaftsmission nicht. Das ist korrekt. Ich meine, da rede ich halt direkt mit dem amerikanischen Wissenschaftler, und dann muss man mit der NASA verhandeln, dass der sein Geld kriegt oder so. Also es ist vielleicht doch ein bisschen anders, ja.
Haben wir noch einen wichtigen Aspekt übersehen, den man jetzt vielleicht noch mal touchieren sollte?
Ja, eigentlich, finde ich, haben wir genug geredet. Mir fällt jetzt auch nichts mehr ein. Aber was man vielleicht sagen kann, ist, dass wir auch eine Website haben von der ESA, wo man immer hingucken kann, www.esa.int, wie International. Und das Thema SSA gibt es unter Schrägstrich SSA. Also www.esa.int.slash oder Schrägstrich SSA. Da kann man sich dann auch noch ein bisschen informieren. Und wenn es interessiert, ein bisschen nachlesen, worüber wir jetzt geredet haben.
Und auch alle anderen Links zu den Details und Agreements und Gruppen. Die hier im Podcast zum Gespräch gekommen sind, die finden sich wie immer in den Show notes zu der Sendung unter Raumzeitstrich podcast.de. Auch das sollte mal wieder gesagt werden, aber das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich sowieso alle schon. Ja, dann bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch Danke zu sagen. Litlef, Kroschni, das war es dann hier mit der Ausgabe 34. Und ja, ich hoffe, ihr seid auch bei dem nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei, wenn es hier heißt, ab ins Weltall mit Raumzeit.